when you wake up generally what the
research shows is that your brain is
primed to be able to focus for the first
four hours of the day the first four
hours of the day tend to be for most of
us the time of day when your brain has
the most fuel and when your speed of
processing is awesome and when you are
able to direct your attention at what
you need to be focused on there's a
caveat to this you can manufacture
boosts of productivity and boosts of
feeling like you've got a little bit
more brain power number one immediately
after you exercise if you have a burst
of cardio 30 minutes is what a lot of
the research says but if you have a
burst of cardio you will get a little
bit of increase in fuel another thing
that helps is getting outside when you
start to feel your energy and your focus
start to go to empty getting outside is
another way to give yourself a boost of
brain power but generally speaking
everybody you need to start to marry
mornings with peak productivity if you
can own your mornings if you can put
that thing that matters to you first
thing in the morning and make a little
bit of progress on it you are going to
start to feel like you are more in
control you're going to start to see
yourself using your best brain power and
your highest level of fuel at the thing
that matters most to you
need motivation you better watch a top
10 with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best mel robbins and my take on
her top 10 rules of success
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two dream with the lid off
give yourself permission
to dream with the lid off
this is really important and the reason
why this is important is because i
guarantee you
that right now you are not even allowing
yourself
to fully
dream or think about or set goals that
are truly aligned with what you deeply
want in your heart
that you aren't even able to manifest
properly because you're not even honest
with yourself about what you actually
want this is a really common thing
because you're allowing your self-doubt
you are allowing your fears your anxiety
your insecurity you're allowing where
you are to dictate and limit where you
want to go and so step one super
important you must allow yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system
i write about the ras for short the
reticular activity system extensively in
the high five habit
the ras is a filter in your mind and you
can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do
in order to teach yourself how to
dream with the lid off
is to
adopt a simple habit every single
morning i do a very simple thing
i write down five things that i want
that's it
when i start my day after i get up on
the alarm rings i make my bed i pull on
my exercise clothes i set an intention i
high-five myself in the mirror i then go
out into the kitchen i crack open my
high five journal and then inside the
journal there are prompts that walk me
through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head
and you physically put them on a piece
of paper research shows that you're 42
more likely to achieve those goals
simply by writing them down that's
pretty cool
secondly your mind is paying attention
and when you take deliberate action and
you write down what you want
you are signaling to your brain
that you
deserve to have these things you are
signaling to your brain that you do want
those things you're not just going to
think about them these are things that
matter to you and that helps train your
mind to allow you to let the desires
flow through you because right now
you're not manifesting properly because
you're not even allowing yourself to
dream with the lid off so that's step
number one you're going to start writing
down five things that you want every
single morning as a way to train your
mind to let you dream freely rule number
three
visualize
the reason why visualization and
picturing yourself succeeding and
allowing yourself to feel the happiness
and the pride that comes with picturing
a positive future
the reason why that's as important is
let's say shelley does that every single
day this week
every day she wakes up she walks for
five minutes and as she's walking on
that treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10k in six months and how
proud she is
every time she does that she is
changing what's going on up here
this isn't something i made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective if shelley wakes up or
if you wake up every single morning
and instead of thinking about the worst
case instead of looking at your body in
the mirror and going i'm so fat i'm so
out of shape i'll never run a 10k this
is never going to happen why didn't i
exercise last year i hate my flabby
stomach i hate my my big thighs i hate
how out of shame i'm embarrassed to go
like if that's what you're thinking
then that is what
you're allowing your brain
to continue to filter the world through
if you start
teaching yourself the skill of
visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now
is you start to think like the kind of
person that does a 10k
if after an entire week what shelly does
is she get looks in the mirror and she
goes i'm getting stronger every day i'm
really proud of myself even though i'm
i'm feeling flabby i'm not saying you're
flabby shelly but even though i'm
feeling flabby i'm doing the work i can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10k
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new
mind because she's been visualizing
every single day
the new mind just seven to ten days
later is gonna go oh wait a minute i'm
in shape i'm proud i'm doing this why do
you sign up
it's gonna filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to
this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why i'm so glad you're doing it rule
number four identify important things
when i hear the word productivity
i don't want you to think about plowing
through a to-do list
because part of the reason why you don't
feel productive
is because you're busy doing the things
that aren't important to you
yeah do you need to make sure you have
milk or you got almond milk or oat milk
in the fridge of course you do but have
you ever noticed that all the busy crap
in life
tends to take care of itself
that you don't really need to focus your
time and energy on the minutia that's on
your to-do list because that stuff tends
to grab your attention
what you really need to do is figure out
how to create time and how to create the
focus that you need
in order to feel like you are making
progress
on the important things
and that's really
what productivity means to me
you get all kinds of stuff done you're
really busy in your life aren't you
but are you getting progress made
on the important things
probably not because that's the
challenge for most of us and so first
things first when it comes to trying to
have a breakthrough in productivity you
need a game plan
you need to have a very short list every
week of what actually matters to you
okay
because i guarantee you if you were to
do an audit of the way that you spend
your time this week you would probably
see
that 95 of your time
is spent on things that you really don't
care about
and even more scary i bet you don't even
realize how much time you are wasting
just mindlessly scrolling through social
media or sitting on the couch with the
tv on also answering emails
that is the least productive way to
spend your time multitasking spending
your time just sort of zoning out on
things that don't matter
what i want you to do is i want you
right now to think about
what is it between now and the end of
this week for example what is it
that matters to you what's the most
important thing
that you would love to make progress on
that you never seem to find the time
okay
it's a whole nother conversation for us
to talk about whether or not you
actually have time because the fact is
you do have time you have plenty of time
to make small amount of progress every
single day on what matters to you
what you do not have right now is you do
not have a plan
for
prioritizing the important stuff in your
life also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five set boundaries if you
struggle with boundaries i want you to
know you're not alone and this is super
common
and um one of the reasons why i'm
excited to share everything that i've
learned about boundaries with you is
because i used to be the kind of person
that had zero boundaries i mean nada
nothing zilch
nothing in fact there were periods of my
life where it was worse than zero
because i was so attached in romantic
relationships that i literally would
become like a human amoeba
in my romantic relationships i mean i
was like literally if it's possible to
have negative boundaries meaning you
like somehow go in a totally different
direction
that was me and so if somebody as
insecure
and as uh emotionally attached in
relationships and as people pleasing as
me can figure out how to
identify
communicate
and uphold boundaries in my life
you can learn how to do this too okay
and so that's what we're going to unpack
in this video
so i think a big question because a lot
of people talk about boundaries they
know they need boundaries but
they don't
have good boundaries why is that
well the reason why
we don't have good boundaries is because
none of us were trained how to set them
i mean i want you to think about your
childhood for a minute
your childhood with your caregivers your
parents or grandparents whoever it is
naturally an imbalance right
like when you come into this world you
are born into a particular family you're
born into a particular culture religion
economic situation a place in the world
a race like a religion and
based on where you were born and to whom
you were born into in terms of the
family structure
there were all kinds of rules that you
had to follow and if you did not follow
those rules
there were consequences and so can you
imagine
if you as like an eight-year-old started
to try to express boundaries literally
like mom cooks a uh you know a pot pot
roast dinner and you cross your arms
you're like you know mom
uh this is a boundary cross for me i
have decided that i'm no longer eating
meat
uh your mom would probably go guess what
youngster
you not eating dinner is a boundary
crossing for me you're not getting up
from this table until you finish what's
on your plate and so
saying boundaries when you're little
doesn't really work for the adults in
your life
and that's why you never learned how to
do it and by the way your parents were
probably never taught how to have
boundaries either and so
i want to start at the very beginning
okay
where do you even begin
where do you even begin when it comes to
learning how to set healthy boundaries
okay
so
first things first where you're going to
begin is you're going to start to think
about boundaries in a completely new way
okay
the number one mistake that we all make
i made it you're making it right now is
when you think about boundaries you are
thinking about other people first okay
you're thinking about boundaries uh and
believing that your boundaries are rules
in a relationship that define respect
and that somehow your boundaries are
going to control or change someone
else's behavior
that is the exact opposite of how you
should be thinking about boundaries okay
and i'm going to give you a bunch of
examples don't worry i didn't realize
this this is why i was lousy at setting
boundaries because i thought that my
boundaries control what other people do
no no no no no so how do i want you to
think about boundaries okay
boundaries
are rules that you create
about your own behavior
yep i'm going to say that again
boundaries are rules that you create
about your own behavior rule number six
reframe negative patterns
understand
that
you can find people to support you
you will always find people to criticize
you
watch though how when somebody outside
of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking
that gets triggered that disempowers you
that i won't have any words
you won't have any words let's go deeper
than that is it something about being
loved or being unworthy or not being
good enough what is underneath i won't
have the words
yeah they won't be the right words and i
it won't be good enough yeah okay and so
do you have an opinion that you're not
good enough or not deserving of success
or that you're not
smart enough to make a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you
that you say to yourself
that i'm stupid that they're okay there
we go that's a good one not a good one
but you know what i mean that's a good
one because that's my baby okay i'm a
piece of
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that
i don't i don't know who told me that
when did you start believing that
so it's a little girl yeah
god i've just been saying it for so long
i i don't know that's okay she said i've
been saying it for so long i don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're going to start to connect the
dots okay and so here's the thing
at some point
you started telling yourself whatever
i'm a piece
as a strategy
you did it on purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well i'm a piece of you actually got
really quiet and you didn't get hit
or maybe when you said that you uh
removed yourself from situations
when you would have been abused or
something it worked because it protected
you as weird as it sounds yeah is that
are you seeing something what are you
seeing
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah we couldn't
make noise and okay
and if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble
so do you guys see the link now between
why she has a concern about finding her
words
oh yeah i didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so
every time that you
are in a situation where you need to
speak up how many of you relating to
this by the way
i have a theory about all of us
that we have
patterns and strategies that we we
created when we were little
in order to survive situations
and what she
internalized was don't speak up
and you're a piece of [ __ ] you do
and
believe me that protected your ass it
worked because you didn't speak up and
you didn't get in trouble with your dad
right and i still got the love so if i
speak up now i'm going to lose my dad's
love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got
written
when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked the problem is now
that you're working now it's not working
now
it's not working now not working now and
see
exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not
present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on a stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up
you're yes freeze and you're going to go
five four three two one the only thing
to
that actually overrides this pattern is
to speak
and through speaking
you will see
that you're not a piece of [ __ ]
you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
i guess i'm just a piece of something to
say
that's right and i also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff
even the heavy stuff
because it loses its grip on me it works
for me it may not work for you
but it's something to try rule number
seven manifest what you want first of
all you've got to give yourself
permission to really
have what you want okay because you got
to have the thing that you're
visualizing be something that is
authentically something that you want
number two
you must see yourself taking the steps
the tiny actions and doing the work that
will lead you to creating or having what
you want
third you gotta feel in your body what
it feels like to do the work and you
also have to feel pride as you see
yourself doing the work because that
amplifies your mind body and spirit
really
imprinting and training and preparing
for it and fourth
obviously you got to take the actions
and all of that manifesting and
preparing inspires you to take the
actions
but one place where so many folks get
stuck when they start trying to make
manifesting a daily habit
is you go and you know what you want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine
what the steps are that you need to take
to get there
and you don't have a clue
your mind goes blank if this is you i'm
so excited that you're watching this
because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend mel robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire
and the power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
now i'm not just making this up there's
extraordinary research that was just
written about in the harvard business
school review they did eight different
studies at the university of wisconsin
where they were studying the power of
objectivity and with thousands of
participants here's what they found when
participants tried to visualize
themselves
doing hard things
immediately the participants when they
thought about themselves doing something
hard like let's just say asking for a
raise okay
i want you to imagine yourself asking
for a raise or applying for that dream
job when you visualize yourself doing it
you immediately focus in on minutia you
start imagining all kinds of things that
could go wrong you start arguing against
yourself and doubt comes flooding in you
have a very cautious mindset when you
place yourself in those scenarios
however if you were to visualize me mel
robbins asking for that raise
immediately your mindset switches to
being very bold being creative seeing
all kinds of opportunities and in fact
when you not only visualize me your
friend mel robbins asking for that raise
that you want when you give me advice
you're super enthusiastic you're like
mel you should go for it and i bet in
your life
you have probably
told friends or loved ones you should
ask for more money and you mean it
because you're visualizing them but you
yourself
won't visualize yourself doing that you
talk yourself out of it we've all had
this experience you yourself are
probably sitting there going right now i
constantly tell my friends you deserve
more you should break up with that jerk
you should go for it
but when it comes to yourself
you see the excuses in depth so i want
you to leverage not only this common
sense but this research to your
advantage when it comes to manifesting
pick what you want and then if your mind
goes blank when it comes to seeing
yourself do the work literally just
insert your friend mel robbins or insert
anybody that you love rule number eight
focus on progress
part of the reason why you don't feel
productive is because you're trying to
complete everything and so let's take
one of the things that i saw somebody
write that you want to
clean up one of the spare rooms in your
apartment or in your house that maybe
there's a spare bedroom and you have
been wanting to turn it into a home
office or maybe one of the kids has
moved out of the house and you want to
declutter that room like a project
around organizing maybe it's something
in your garage or your basement or hey
here's one for me
our daughter moved out and started her
life uh you know post college and our
other daughter is out in los angeles
going to college and we no joke
have
three garbage bags full of clothes
that somebody needs to go through to
figure out what needs to be donated what
could you actually sell because it still
has tags on it and it has been sitting
there for two months so maybe you have a
pile of that kind of stuff in your house
this is not a priority for me
i'm perfectly fine with it sitting in
the room where our laundry is the
priority for me this week is to carve
out dedicated time to hang out with our
16 year old son and do something fun
together because we spend a lot of time
together but we don't get intentional
about doing something specific but if
you want to declutter for example here's
where we all go wrong you identify what
you want to do and then you think you
got to get it done
in order for me to go through two bags
of clothing for example in order for you
to clear out your garage that could take
you two days to do it the right way
right
because
you know if you don't give yourself
enough time then you're gonna piles and
so then you think i can't get it done
and so then you never schedule it right
okay
we're not gonna worry about completion
everybody we're going to worry about
progress
so when you think about things in terms
of progress it can shrink the amount of
time that you need maybe all that you're
going to do is you're going to work on
one dresser in the room or you're gonna
work on one shelving unit in the garage
and by simply making the time to number
one identify what matters to you and
number two identify what meaningful
progress could look like
you will now shrink the amount of time
you will define the project and you can
make the time for it and simply just
doing that is going to make you feel
more productive based on the research
all right now let me talk about um
what you need to do okay i literally
have notes for this oh there we go and i
just lost it because i really want to
make sure that i teach you all this
stuff so um here becca can you help me
because this is not oh because my thing
is not never mind guys i am tr i am
trying multitasking is not how you be
productive and you are watching me
multitask right now
we're going to get into some of the
science now
so now that is how you leverage
something called the progress principle
okay the progress principle is really
important when it comes to productivity
this is a concept that i first learned
about in the harvard business review so
if it's in the harvard business review
everybody very fancy must be accurate
right if it's coming from harvard well
the progress principle is a study that
comes from a study where researchers
looked at i believe it was 14 000 work
journals and what they found after
looking at the work journals of how
people spent their time fourteen
thousand people is that at the end of
the week the people that felt like they
had been the most productive and the
people who felt the most fulfilled by
their work week were the people who
simply made progress on something that
mattered and so by you identifying what
matters to you this week and by you
identifying a way that you can make a
small amount of progress on it you are
leveraging this research research from
harvard business review about what
creates productivity and meaning and
fulfillment in your life and that's
making progress on something that
matters rule number nine do the work you
need to do the work okay
you got to do the work because it's only
through your actions that you will
accomplish what you want let's say uh
that you've always wanted to climb a
particular mountain okay there's a
mountain called haystack it's not even
that tall so i should probably pick a
bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time
and then all of a sudden it starts to
rain and you go i don't think i want to
do this because i don't think i feel
like doing this and next thing you know
you are back in the car driving back
down the road to that little diner that
you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse
and you have abandoned ship you now have
literally become your own obstacle you
talked yourself out of it you started to
doubt yourself you told yourself you
weren't ready and that you didn't feel
like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain
you must stop creating excuses for why
you can't or don't feel like it and you
must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also
been putting in the time every day
consistently to not only see yourself
walking up that trail step by step but
that you have felt yourself pushing
through the resistance the fear the
obstacles the
the excuses that are stopping you now
and feel proud in every fiber of your
being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud i knew
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is be authentic
so many of us have this perfectionism
gene and the reason why we're
perfectionists is we're trying to
insulate ourselves from criticism that
if you get it perfect no one will give
you feedback if you get it right
nobody's going to criticize you if you
do it perfect then no one will be able
to attack you and the problem with that
and that's just another side of the same
coin which is the fear of disappointing
people you're managing not disappointing
people not by lying and not by being
codependent but by actually trying to be
a perfectionist so that nobody
criticizes you so let me tell you a
story about the fear of disappointing
people in my own life because this is
the biggest trigger in my life i mean it
goes back to being in fourth grade right
it's there and this is another thing i i
literally have to remind myself of this
everybody every single day you cannot
remove the things that trigger you you
can't if you've been doing a pattern
since fourth grade there will be things
for the rest of your life that will
trigger that pattern to come up but you
can always choose not to repeat the
pattern so you'll be triggered and be
afraid that you're going to disappoint
somebody that's real that's normal it's
natural it's part of being a human being
i think it's interwoven into every
relationship where you love somebody but
you don't have to behave the way that
you always behaved when you're nervous
about disappointing somebody so let me
give you a dumb story you ready when my
husband and i got married my father gave
us this really incredible gift he gave
us an antique pool table i grew up in
muskegon michigan where brunswick was
founded and my dad has a hobby of going
to garage sales and estate sales and
buying old dilapidated pool tables and
then he restores them so when chris and
i got married he bought us an old
dilapidated pool table from the same era
as our house which is the 1870s he
restored the whole thing and then
recently he and i rented a u-haul and we
drove this sucker from muskegon michigan
to boston massachusetts my dad and i
took a road trip get there and we
assemble the pool table in what used to
be our playroom fast forward three or
four years the speaking business takes
off my business starts to grow we have
people that work for us and my kids are
older we don't need a playroom we need
an office the pool table is in the
middle of this thing for the first two
years of having the office we kept the
pool table there why because i didn't
want my dad to be disappointed because i
love him now he visits our house twice a
year for two or three days with my mom
and i kept this thing occupying a third
of our office for two years and then i
realized i'm being
ridiculous i'm being absolutely
ridiculous now here's the thing will he
be disappointed if i take the pool table
down absolutely definitely there are
always going to be things that you do
decisions that you have to make in your
life in your business for your family
that will disappoint other people it's
unavoidable but the fact that he's going
to be disappointed should never be the
reason that i don't do something that is
aligned with my values now let's take it
a step further when you make a decision
that is likely going to disappoint
people or that does still make the
decision because it's your life there's
nothing worse than when you start to
rob your future and your life and your
happiness because you're so focused on
other people however if you love people
you can still take care of them when you
make that decision so let me go back to
the example of the pool table so i knew
i was going to take it down i knew my
father was going to be disappointed i
was disappointed i don't have a big
house so i don't you know i don't have
the room for a huge pool table i don't
have a finished basement like a lot of
people i don't have like a cool garage
game room thing like i just don't have
it i called him first and said i need to
talk to you about something you know the
pool table i love the pool table dad my
business is growing so much i actually
need an office and oh great it'll be
great in the office and i'm like well
yeah it would except i have you know
three or four people showing up we got
to put some desks in there for now even
went down well you could put a piece of
plywood they could work on the pool
table and then they could do the thing
and then the thing and now my heart is
racing because i don't want to
disappoint my dad and now he's fighting
for the and i had to just say for me dad
here's what's going to happen i'm going
to hire professional movers in the pool
table business to disassemble this with
love and care you're gonna store it
beautifully when i either get a
full-time office off-site or i build a
barn or i build a different house this
will have its own beautiful room
dedicated to you so we had this
beautiful conversation now was he
disappointed absolutely when they come
to the house and visit which they just
did and they walk into the office do i
feel a pang you better believe i do it
doesn't matter that's all normal i still
need to make the decisions that i need
to make and the difference what's
changed is how i relate to that fear so
instead of what i would do in the past
is i would make a decision that doesn't
serve me i'd leave the pool table and
then i'd be all about it i'd leave the
pool table as a way to make my dad happy
but it makes me miserable to leave it
there because i need the space right and
then i'd be kind of annoyed and then
he'd come and i'd fake play pool because
i kind of want to write you know you
know what i'm saying like we do all this
that's not real and what i've been able
to do
for myself in some instances when i
catch it is to hit it head-on and to be
authentic and to still take care of
people and what i've also come to learn
is that people can be disappointed in
you and they still love you you know
you're never going to get around this
everybody in your family is going to be
disappointed with you probably once a
day probably and you have the ability to
retrain how you respond to that trigger
that rises up in you where you start to
fear that you're disappointing somebody
and the answer really is make the
decision that's aligned with your values
and the thing that supports you and then
take care of the person by being honest
and straightforward about it dealing
with their disappointment head-on
because that's really the adult thing to
do and that's what you do when you love
somebody the way we've all been handling
it myself included is manipulation lying
resentment withholding and that doesn't
serve anybody
there is no fast track to transformation
you have to work on it in little ways
every day you can't buy self-esteem or
self-love you must build it you must
stand face to face with the part of you
that you hate
you must forgive yourself for the hurt
that you've caused especially the hurt
you've caused yourself
and then you've got to do the work to
become a better you
it's the only way to create the
self-respect and build the self-esteem
that you want you can change there are
do-overs in life because you get one
every single morning when you wake up
look in the mirror and decide who you're
going to be today you can choose you can
change no you can't go back in time but
you can have your own back as you use
the time that you have now to take
control and create a new chapter that
makes you proud of who you are
the hardest part of all this is flipping
your focus
from what you hate and are trying to fix
toward what you want to create
remember the windshield in a car is
bigger than the rear view mirror for
good reason you're not supposed to go
backwards you're supposed to drive your
life forward and that means you must
start looking ahead
yeah you screwed up me too the worst
things that you've done witnessed or
survived they are your most powerful
teachers so stop making yourself wrong
about what happened and unpack it
understand it
face yourself in the mirror and learn
the lessons that are woven into every
mistake
every regret you ever have and every
painful thing you've ever experienced
here's the profound insight i gained
that i want you to hear you aren't
broken
you're just blocked
forgive yourself for all the things you
did while you were just trying to
survive your mind collects mental lint
that's right that's all that doubt is
that's all that fear is that's all that
anxiety is that's all that worry is it's
all the people pleasing is
this is lint from life that is collected
in your brain and you know what lint
stands for something get your pencils
ready
you lose inspiration due to negative
thoughts
that's all that's happening
you're not broken you're just blocked
the filter in your mind is blocked just
like a dryer filter gets blocked by lint
and you can't think this stuff away you
got to take action
and the single most effective tool on
the planet hands down to wipe away the
lint in your mind to wipe away the doubt
to wipe away the fear to wipe away the
anxiety
is the five second rule
i'm dead serious about this
when you feel
the fear rise up when you feel the
self-doubt start to block
when you feel the anxiety start to take
over when you feel like you're losing
the inspiration to move you're just
gonna count backwards five four three
two one
i know it sounds dumb
but trust me on this one counting
backwards five four three two one wipes
the lint
off the filter in your brain
that lint that makes you lose your
inspiration to act due to negative
thoughts
and once you get to one it's clear
so your confidence and your courage can
flow right through you this one is like
really important
you need to do the work okay
you got to do the work
because it's only through your actions
that you will accomplish what you want
let's say uh that you've always wanted
to climb a particular mountain okay
there's a mountain called haystack it's
not even that tall so i should probably
pick a bigger one but let's just call it
haystack mountain you've always wanted
to climb haystack mountain you pull up
to haystack mountain
and you get out of the car you park at
the you know national forest parking lot
and you make the mistake of looking up
at the mountain which is the end goal
right
and you notice it's up in the clouds
and then you start to think oh my god
that's a really far way away
you know i don't really know how i feel
about doing this anymore because that
looks like it's going to take a really
long time and then all of a sudden it
starts to rain and you go i don't think
i want to do this because i don't think
i feel like doing this and next thing
you know you are back in the car driving
back down the road to that little diner
that you saw and instead of climbing the
mountain that you've always dreamt of
climbing you've now
come up with an excuse and you have
abandoned ship you now have literally
become your own obstacle you talked
yourself out of it you started to doubt
yourself you told yourself you weren't
ready and that you didn't feel like it
you pull the rip cord you're out of
there in order to have what you want in
life
you must stop staring at the top of that
mountain you must stop creating excuses
for why you can't or don't feel like it
and you must put your head down
and look at the first step in front of
you
and then you must take the action and
start walking toward what you want and
it'll be a hell of a lot easier for you
to do that if you have also
been putting in the time every day
consistently
to not only see yourself
walking
up that trail step by step but that you
have felt yourself pushing through the
resistance the fear the obstacles the
the excuses that are stopping you now
and feel proud in every fiber of your
being as you push through those
obstacles and see yourself and feel
yourself doing the work that's how you
manifest properly
and if you do that before you pull into
the
national park parking lot
if you look up at that mountain and you
see clouds and it starts raining it
won't matter
because you've already rehearsed this
moment in your mind body and spirit
and you my friend will start walking up
that trail
and you're going to be proud
that's how you use manifesting to get
what you want that's how you leverage
all the science and research to train
and prepare your mind body and spirit to
help you get what you want and that's
how you hack the motivation and
inspiration that you need to take the
actions that get you everything that you
want and deserve in life the dallas uber
driver oh so as somebody who has gotten
into
countless ubers and some small
percentage of them know who i am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um
yeah the uber driver in dallas that's in
this book um i get choked up when i
think about him
uh an aha moment i'm choked up
i get choked up
because
what happens for me every single
day is and you hear from people every
single day
you've got millions and millions of
people that
are inspired by empowered by impacted by
your content there are people out there
that
use your work as a lifeline
and it is humbling
and what i am
really present to
in the work that i'm putting out in the
stuff that i'm sharing whether it's my
failures or the things that i'm using
that are helping me and my own struggles
is just
how much people are holding themselves
back
and how
much pain people feel
because
most folks know
what they dream about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against
what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
i hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going i got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
i don't know if i'm worth that i don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this i don't think i'm good enough i
failed so many times i can't go through
that door
and that's the problem i want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life
that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you
and you are actively arguing against it
you're bringing yourself down you're
beating yourself out like people will
cheer for you and me they won't cheer
for themselves
i'm the same way
and so this uber driver
the story that you're talking about i
get into the car
and
we start driving and i'm on the phone as
we're driving and i'm having a
conversation with somebody about this
daytime talk show that i launched which
was a dream with sony pictures
television and then
uh was promptly fired after season one
it was a huge failure because we didn't
make it to season two
huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life
and so i'm talking to this person about
the talk show i hang up the phone and
this uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh i can't believe you're in my
cab
and i'm like why and he says because i i
want to talk to you about something i
think you can help me and i'm like great
how can i help you and he says
i have a dream of being a oscar-winning
uh actor and creating opportunities for
other black and latino men to do the
same in acting and i'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
dallas
right you know the guy's 25 and so
i i go you know the game is in new york
and la i mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in dallas
but why are you not in la why are you
not in new york and he's like you're
right you're right you're right i need
to move to la like why not
and he says i have 700 in my bank
account and i'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for and so we have this
whole conversation and i write about it
in this book
where
i am actively arguing for his dream and
he is actively arguing against his dream
and
what is so sad
is throughout this conversation tom he's
like you're right 700 could get me there
you're right i am only 25. you're right
if i keep thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking about what i want
to be doing i'm not only going to drive
in circles my whole life is going to
spin in circles as i think about what i
want and i don't do [ __ ] about it
and then you are going to find yourself
not at 25 but at 45 or 65 and you're
going to be so filled with regret that
you never put a put a bet on yourself
and so
this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
california and me giving him a bunch of
tools that i talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not i don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us
we do not know how to do it for
ourselves you must
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal
this is a major mistake that people make
they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal
if you've ever made a vision board
think about what you put on the vision
board you put up just the beach house or
the million dollars in the bank are you
crossing the finish line are you
launching that business are you having
the body that you want are you driving
the maserati whatever it is the end goal
is what you put up on a vision board
that is not what you're going to do when
you manifest if you start focusing on
crossing the finish line of the marathon
that is a one-way ticket to being
unmotivated and completely discouraged
in fact research shows that if all you
do is focus on the thing that you want
and you just focus on that vision of you
and your bikini body or you with the
love of your life on your arms or you at
the
oscars winning that award or the grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal
you start to feel really unmotivated and
discouraged because you're nowhere near
it that's where manifesting comes in
because we're not going to focus on the
end goal
you got to pick something that you want
in order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end
it's about the bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be
but when it comes to manifesting
once you've given yourself permission to
dream with the lid off and really want
what you want to feel the pull of that
thing now we got to talk about the path
that connects where you are with where
you want to go
and this is all about visualizing the
little steps there's a lot of research
that proves why visualizing the steps is
the most important thing that you could
do
there was a study done at ucla for
example
where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a
close their eyes visualize in their mind
and feel in their body
themselves taking the test
and then walking up
to a board where the tests
scores were posted
and finding their name and seeing an a
plus
that's what group a the vision board
group were told to do
to visualize themselves achieving what
they wanted
group b
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room
sitting down at the desk
and studying
and staying up late and putting in the
work studying and preparing for the
tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it group b
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered group b
you got the correct answer the reason
why group b
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work
and it's only through actions that you
will get the result that you want
preparing your mind and visualizing
yourself doing it
lowers your resistance and leads to you
taking the action that's why manifesting
works you know the same is true in
sports there's all kinds of research in
sports psychology in fact our olympic
athletes for the u.s olympic team
they hire sports psychologists to train
our top olympic athletes particularly
after they've been injured
in visualizing themselves competing
when you coach an athlete to mentally
rehearse every single detail about going
through the competition you are training
the mind body and spirit to show up and
dominate this is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right
so manifestation properly remember what
it is manifesting is preparing your mind
body and spirit to do the work it's
aligning your mind body and spirit with
what you want it removes the obstacles
that would normally stop you which then
prepares and motivates you to take the
actions to succeed so in the case of
athletes who visualize themselves and
see themselves doing all the steps over
and over they're removing the nerves
they're removing all the programming
related to the injury they are preparing
their mind body and spirit to go in and
frickin dominate and so are you you know
when you're about to meet a friend
somebody you really like at a cafe
you're gonna go have a cup of tea
what do you feel right before you walk
in the door
excitement enthusiasm energy joy
uh
positive nervousness like that that kind
of like
butterflies even in a positive sense
yeah so at this moment i was 51 years
old
in 51 years of being alive i don't ever
remember feeling
that feeling about seeing myself wow
for the first time in my life i had this
sensation
that i was excited
to see the human being mel robbins
now i've been excited to see an outfit
or excited to see a haircut
i have never been excited to see the
person
and so i round the corner and this
sense of how profound this is is hitting
me
and i'm standing there
brushing my teeth and i realize
something really wild
there are always two of you in the
bathroom together
there's you
and there is a human being in the mirror
a person who needs you
a person who has been waiting for you to
wake up and realize they are there
and they need you to see them and to
hear them and to love them and to
support them
and so what's interesting because you
brought up morning routines right is
that we all talk about the importance of
setting our day up because it's how it
ends up we talk about gratitude and
meditation and we know the extraordinary
benefits of it but i don't think anybody
has truly amplified the fact that there
is this dirty habit that we all have
every single morning that is a part of
your morning routine unless you have
weeded this out
and it is a habit of either ignoring
yourself
or
beating the heck out of yourself
every single morning in the mirror i
mean 91 of women don't like how they
look 50 of us can't even look at
ourselves in the mirror one of the
things that i think you should always
come back to
first is take a look at how you set your
day up because how you set it up is how
it ends up how do i set my day up so
that i'm practicing what i call simple
discipline simple discipline is nothing
more than making and keeping simple
promises to yourself repeating it every
day the way that you start to change the
big things is you change the small
things make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so how do
you build simple discipline here are
some core skills that i do every morning
that have helped me number one
i do not sleep with the phone
number two
when the alarm goes off on my phone it's
not near me so i have to get my ass out
of bed i get up i make my bed i get
moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal i take 10 minutes to
myself to plan my day when i do that my
day is incredible i believe that how you
start your day dictates how the day goes
you should not just adopt somebody
else's morning routine and expect it to
work for you you need to customize this
you are unique i think about how do you
come alive for yourself in the morning
what are the five senses what's the
first thing that you see
when you wake up for me it's a painting
that i manifested out of thin air it
reminds me that what you put your mind
to and what you work toward
it will become a reality i always light
incense because it makes my senses and
my nose come alive i'm super mindful
over what i taste first thing in the
morning my grandma always had vinegar in
the morning with honey and hot water i
picked the one thing that matters to me
today you're a big proponent of the
growth mindset you guys talk about it
all the time on the show right so
researchers wanted to know what is the
most empowering way to motivate kids
through a really big challenge okay they
divide the kids into three groups this
takes the marshmallow test to a whole
nother level you got one group of kids
that are doing a challenging task and
they're getting the fixed mindset praise
which we all know does not work oh tom
you're so smart oh tom i love your
glasses that's going to help you oh tom
you got a great smile oh tom you know i
i just love so much about you i know you
can do this so that's one group the
second group gets the growth mindset
kind of phrase tom you are such a hard
worker tom your perseverance is
unbelievable tom you just keep going
that does better obviously than telling
you that you're smart because it makes
you motivated to work hard the third
group
they just got a simple high five the
researchers didn't even say anything to
the kids they just walked up gave them a
high five the group of kids that got a
simple high five outperformed outworked
through all of the challenges all of the
other forms of praise why
because a high five is something deeper
than praise
it fulfills your most fundamental needs
as a human being
when somebody high-fives you you feel
seen
you feel heard
and you feel like somebody has
acknowledged
you for the unique person that you are
and one of the things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting
evidence
as you're doing the work as you're going
through your day it will help you if you
train your mind to start scanning the
world and spotting evidence
that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because
if you get into a negative mindset if
you start thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother i'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should i keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic
negative protective
scared and doubtful stance
your mind will continue to show you
reasons why there's nobody on hinge
worth talking to your mind will continue
to show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend corrine crabtree always talks
about that transformational moment and
when your mind goes negative your mind
starts to scan the world and will show
you more reasons to stop
and the power of training your mind to
spot positive signs is very simple
the power is that your mind will start
to show you reasons to keep going
your mind will help you take the step
your mind will encourage you to feel
optimistic to feel empowered just like
you woke up today on a tuesday and it
was february 22nd
2022 and those numbers are lining up and
that makes you in your heart and soul go
whoa
something cool could happen today like
that only happens like once in my
lifetime those numbers are going to line
up like that today
is a really cool day let's go do
something with this
you could create that kind of attitude
every single freaking day of your life
you could
if you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that i
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why i love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself where
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my god it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a heartbeat
there we go
check that out
if you say
brain
mind show me a heart today guess what's
gonna happen that damn dog biscuit
it's gonna show it's gonna you're gonna
be like there's a heart you're gonna
look out at the sky and you're gonna see
a heart shape oh right there in the
mountains there's a heart shape in the
mountains in southern vermont you're
going to see it in the clouds what
you're doing when you tell your mind
what's important to you is you're
telling your mind and the filter in your
brain to change in real time and allow
into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by god those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me mel robbins on social media you will
see every day i am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this i
don't wanna see all the reasons why i'm
unhappy i don't want to see
uh everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good uh marriage or relationship
and i don't want to see that and and and
have my mind process it as evidence that
it's never going to happen for me
i want my mind to reprogram itself and
see other people's businesses and see
other people getting healthy and see
other people in relationships and i want
my mind to say
yeah if they can do it i can do it
that's evidence if that person can get
healthy so can i if that person can find
somebody on hinge so can i if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can i
other people can become evidence that
you can have it too right now your mind
is so [ __ ] up from your past that when
you see what other people have and you
don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
gonna win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what i wanted that sucks
and so what i want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa
this is a once in a lifetime day
everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you going to do with this day
your mind already interpreted this as
wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it i swear to god
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of horse everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a
filter in your brain called the
reticular activating system
the reticular activating system i call
it the ras i like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
ras sits over your brain i'm probably
getting this wrong i'm not a
neuroscientist i could give about
getting it right i just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a phd
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life
that's what i'm here for in your life
i'm here to translate this stuff into
simple believable and actionable things
that you can do
to take all this super cool stuff that
people are researching and apply it to
your normal person's everyday life to
help you
change from the inside out and one of
the coolest things that you have at your
disposal is you have a whole system in
your body that you can
train and change
and one of those things that you can
train and change
that is impacted by that real that word
you're hearing a lot of neuroplasticity
that just means that things are able to
twist and bend and change and you're
able to learn new things for as long as
you're alive
as long as you're breathing everybody
you got a chance to change the way that
you think as long as you are breathing
you got a chance to change from the
inside out how you experience your life
as long as you are still here watching
me people you got a chance to create a
new experience in your life and one of
the things that helps a lot is
understanding that right now all of the
bull from your past has jammed the
filter in your mind body and spirit the
reticular activating system
and it is clouding your ability to look
at the world around you and see
hearts remember this dog treat hearts
look at that there's a heart right there
i had completely forgotten about the
audio book because i was so
focused on this new york times things
and by the way here's another thing
you can't make the new york times list
if you're a self-published author
something i didn't even know when i
started
so
here i thought i'd fail didn't achieve
my dream the whole thing
i get this email
your monthly report is ready and i'm
like monthly report what are they
talking about
i click on that report i open it up i am
literally like oh
my god
audiobooks
audiobooks who
knew audiobooks were a thing
here's what happened
the entire time that i kept going
something amazing was happening lisa
they were going to the hardcover but it
wasn't available they bought the only
thing that was available
the audiobook
the five-second rule
became the number one audiobook of the
year lisa
it to this day is the most successful
self-published audio book
in the history of audible and
it created a brand new partnership that
i have with audible something by the way
that i never
would have had happen
had my hardcover
campaign be successful
and here's the other thing i have never
achieved my goal of being a new york
times selling author and i might never
achieve it
i've never made a traditional bestseller
list
and it proves something that i believe
very deeply and that is that your dreams
and the things that you put on your
vision board have a very important
purpose
they pull you through your fears
they inspire you to take action but they
are not necessarily meant to be achieved
i believe when you pursue your dreams
and you keep going
and you keep telling yourself that if i
work hard something amazing is going to
happen you'll achieve something better
something that you don't even know
or
can even think about right now because
it's not even on your radar screen
those dreams are
dots on the map of your life that pull
you in a direction you're meant to go
but you might never end up there because
you're meant to end up somewhere else
i actually have an incredible quote of
yours about dreams you say when it comes
to your dreams you have two choices
pursue them or be haunted by them
it's true you can't forget a dream
you can
something that you want in your life
once you really want it there are four
techniques that i use whenever i'm gonna
have a difficult conversation that help
me
stay focused on what i need to talk
about instead of getting hijacked by my
emotions number one i always start the
conversation by acknowledging
my responsibility in the mess that we
have to talk about whether it's the fact
that i've avoided dealing with this
sooner or whether there's something that
i've done that's contributed to the
situation i acknowledge it right up
front and one of the reasons why that's
so important is because by accepting
some responsibility you're diffusing the
other person's emotion
you're also honoring them a little bit
and it sets a much more level playing
field for when you get into the
difficult things that you need to talk
about it's also going to put the person
that you're speaking to
a little at ease so they're going to be
able to listen number two you want to
have a goal
never go into a difficult conversation
without an outcome defined before you go
into it the reason why the outcome is so
important is because this conversation
is going to be a roller coaster the
person that you're talking to might get
upset you yourself might feel emotional
at some point whether you're angry or
you're triggered or you get sad and so
when you ride the roller coaster of
emotion the thing that is going to
stabilize your thoughts is the outcome
that you're causing you're having this
conversation because you're committed to
making the relationship better you're
having this conversation because this
isn't working and so we need to end it
powerfully you're having this
conversation
because you want to give somebody some
feedback that's not so fun to tell them
but you're giving it to them because
you're committed to their success okay
so that goal you feel yourself getting
emotional you come back to it you come
back to it you come back to it
third thing you're going to do a lot in
this conversation you're going to listen
and you're going to validate
so you're going to say what you need to
say and then the other person is going
to react
and instead of arguing or debating i
want you to listen and i want you to
validate what the person is saying may
sound counterintuitive but honestly one
of the most powerful things you can do
in any conversation whether you're
fighting with your kids over curfew or
you're arguing with somebody at work
over workloads whatever it may be is
here where the person's at
the moment you say wow
that must be really tough
what you're dealing with or
oh i totally get why you now were
avoiding me
if i felt the way that you felt i'd
probably do the same thing
the second you validate somebody they
immediately stop defending themselves
it's unbelievable actually
unbelievable you've got to try it
validate validate validate it is the
most powerful thing and then once of
course they feel validated that you've
heard them now they can listen
and that's when you come back to the
final thing which is you're going to
restate always the outcome keep coming
back to it keep coming back to it
and yeah it's not going to be fun
it's not going to be easy
you're going to have all kinds of
emotions come up because you've been
avoiding this conversation
but i'm telling you right now
if you find the confidence and the
courage to go and to start this thing
knowledge your responsibility have an
outcome in mind validate the other
person validate validate validate and
keep talking until you hit that outcome
you're going to be really really amazed
at how much easier these things become
and if you want to make it even easier
on yourself rehearse it with another
friend first somebody that's not
involved in the situation because again
difficult conversations comes down to
one important thing
the ability for you to separate your
emotion about doing it from the things
you actually need to talk about and the
outcome that you want to cause if you
can't stand in front of the mirror
and raise your hand and high five
yourself just because you got your ass
out of bed
and you're breathing
you will never get what you want in life
ever
there is something in the resistance to
it and if you unpack the resistance
you will find the reason why you don't
have what you want
you either think you're not worthy of it
or you think that it's kind of stupid or
you have been brought up to believe that
for women in particular you're going to
be [ __ ] or selfish or not likeable if
you're celebrating yourself there is
something in the resistance to you
simply
cheering for yourself one of the biggest
objections that people had to standing
in front of the mirror take a moment
look at yourself and then raise your
hand
as people said over and over and over
again
i haven't done anything
worthy
of high fiving
high fiving feels like a celebration
i don't have the number on the scale
that i want
i don't like my bank account i don't
enjoy what i do for a living i've made a
load of mistakes i'm struggling with
trauma i don't have anything to
celebrate
and what i realized is
people are making a fundamental mistake
you are withholding the very support
empowerment and celebration that you
need to change and to do the hard work
and to face the things that you're
scared of
and that's why
you're not changing when i think back
three years ago where i was like saw one
of your videos or gary's videos or
somebody i'm like oh i just need to
start filming the book lines at these
and it was a it was a moment it was this
little
amount of wisdom inside of me that i
listened to
and i am telling you that is the power
you got to tune out the noise and you
got to learn how to make what i call a
quiet decision yeah quiet decision where
you sh
and you hear what your heart
is is urging you to do let's start with
a metaphor
i want you to think about your life like
a book
a book is divided into chapters
some chapters are boring and a grind to
get through and others are exciting and
you hope they never end and right now
you're in a chapter
[Music]
maybe this chapter of your life is a
grind it's overwhelming and unsatisfying
and you feel stuck reading it over and
over again
maybe you want to start a new chapter
but you don't know what the next chapter
is about and so you keep rereading the
one you're currently in
here's the greatest thing about life
you don't have to know where this next
chapter is going
you just have to start writing it
i want you to envision a blank page
what do you want to write
what do you see for yourself
i don't want you to try to figure out
what job or business you should write on
that page what belongs on that page are
the dreams that you have for yourself
and your life
and all that's required to start writing
is to start saying yes instead of
telling yourself no
yes you should start that podcast
yes you should go back to school
yes you should try to launch that
business
whatever it is that you've been doing
whether you're three years out of
college and it's a job you can't stand
from a major you hate or it's a 20-year
career that you're just burnt out on
or maybe you stepped away from the
workforce to raise your kids or perhaps
like so many people right now you've
been laid off
this is the moment to write your next
chapter
you're not too late
[Music]
you're right on time
all you need is a blank page
and a pen
do
tiny things every day that boost your
mood okay
so we're gonna build your mood muscle
if you can move your body
because negativity gets stored here and
moving your body we know based on the
research simply moving your body for 10
or 20 minutes a day will release
chemicals in your mind
that help you boost your mood the second
thing that will boost your mood is i
want you to make a tiny promise to
yourself every day just one thing that
makes you feel more positive is it
getting up on time
is it eating something healthy
is it only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mocktail i want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the
um comments right now what's one tiny
promise that you can make to yourself
that you're going to do every day it
might just be that you're going to wake
up every day take a deep breath remind
yourself that you're healthy and that's
going to be the tiny promise i want you
to do one tiny promise every day because
keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is
have a zero tolerance policy for your
own negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world i woke up this morning i
looked in the mirror
i looked at the gray hairs that are
coming in particularly like right up
here
and i started to go negative i started
to feel dreary and i went mel cut this
[ __ ] out you gotta fight to stay
positive gal because we are in this for
another couple months and do not succumb
to despair do not start thinking
negative stuff when you have negativity
internally you gotta have a zero
tolerance policy for that
it's one thing to feel what you need to
feel
so that you can move through it it's
another thing to let negativity dwell up
here and start ruminating fi the five
second rule is genius for this count
backwards the second that negative 54321
not listening to it no i am redirecting
my thoughts that's right i am looking
for the things i can control i am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that i can control right now
today
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome to see my recent
interview with mel robbins one on one
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i hope your
business goes bankrupt evan evan you're
a terrible person i spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way